Speaker 1: Let's go next to Stephanie
in Texas. Stephanie, you're on the air.
Stephanie, in Texas, you're on the air, please
unmute, and you'll be able to talk to me.
Speaker 6: Hello. Hello, can you hear me? Hi,
yes, I can. Hi, thanks for taking my call.
Pleasure. And I owe you an apology. Actually, I
tried calling a couple months ago, and I got so
excited that instead of honoring my call, I hung
up on you. I apologize for that. Oh no. So anyway,
and I just wanted to just let you know that we're
not all crazy here in Texas, but just how crazy?
How crazy are things in Texas? Oh, and I wanted to
ask you out. Thank you for the. You did a piece on
the murder charges being dropped against a
woman who tried to seek an abortion. Yes. And I,
you know, there's a lot of things I could. There's
a lot of things I'm trying to like, you know,
to ask you about because there's a lot of things
going on here right now, but that's one of the
ones I think that's really first and foremost.
And do you think that that's something that my
I'm hoping my hope is it will lose steam over time
as people maybe get faced with these more if more
charges come out and people start realizing
it's more of a, you know, wild goose chase to
some extent. Do you think that's going to in your
opinion? Do you think it's going to start being
less of an issue or do you think it's become
people are going to try and push it more?
Speaker 1: I think unfortunately, Stephanie,
I think the whole charges for abortions thing.
I think it's going to be a new tool that we're
going to see a lot of. And in particular,
in late June, the Supreme Court is going to
issue a decision on a on a state abortion case,
and their decision could effectively overturn
Roe v. Wade if that happens. There are 22
states that essentially ban abortion. Those
laws will then become the law of the land.
And I think you're going to see tons of people
charged criminally for seeking abortions,
and it's going to be a dystopian nightmare.
Speaker 6: Mm-Hmm. Yeah. And it's unfortunate
because, you know, obviously, the Roe v. Wade is
a huge tool that people have been able to take
advantage of, and it's just not, you know, I'm
hoping I'm hoping that that won't be the case. But
unfortunately, like you said and June,
we kind of have a deadline here. Now,
have you interviewed Beto O'Rourke yet or is that
something that if you have, have I missed it? And
if you haven't, do you plan on doing that?
Speaker 1: He's not been on. We're interested
in having him on. So far, he's not shown
any interest in being on. So if people want
to tweet Sebadoh and say, Hey, OK? Go to The
David Pakman Show, we would love to have him.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I think I'd follow him. And
I also volunteered to phone bank and and not
knock on doors for him. So hopefully I'll get some
more in out there. But yeah, he's just I'm hoping
that he'll he'll have some, some pull if he gets
elected. Hopefully it's just it's just been so
kind of crazy and I get so frustrated. People
say we don't like it, then move, you know,
that's a really, you know, generic thing to say
to people because we can't just move like our
home and our businesses here and people have
Speaker 1: families and everything. Yeah.
Speaker 6: Excuse me. Stephanie, listen,
Speaker 1: can you get a good bagel
in Texas or is that impossible?
Speaker 6: Actually, yeah. Yeah, you know,
I guess it depends. I if I want to go Drive-Thru
for Bagel, I go to the Einstein brothers, which
I'm sure is like, you know, pretty, pretty basic.
But I have bagels in the air fryer. Actually, it's
pretty funny, like I make them with I have an air
fryer and I found a really good recipe for it's
not like your traditional bagel, so it's not. It's
a little bit more like a it's a little moistur